lesson number one when trying to find a
job in the national football league
when it's mid-june and no one has
offered you a job don't go on social
media and say i'll never play for andy
reid again i'd retire
first andy reads one of the most
respected coaches
in the history of the league and for
le'veon bell who
mishandled ultimately at the end of the
day his contract situation in pittsburgh
did not earn his money with the jets
congratulations to him on getting the
money but he didn't earn it
gets dumped by the jets lands in kansas
city look football's a meritocracy if he
was good enough to play he would have
played he would have been part of things
he would have
he would have had a larger role i
i was amazed how that comment we wrote
about it at pft how that moved the
needle
people were and and i would have never
guessed that people would be so
interested in the story of a guy
who is basically done and and i think
that's what's sad about it he's
he's coming to terms with the fact that
it's over and i think sometimes it's
human nature when you're in that spot to
lash out
at anyone you can instead of
acknowledging
it's my own fault that it's over i i
don't disagree with you totally there
you know yeah he's in
you know he's in a in a tough spot a
spot certainly that he's never been in
in his life where it's like wait
nobody wants me for my physical
abilities and things like that
but you know even with that right like
i mean something must have gone down to
a degree
i mean le'veon bell even unhappy in
pittsburgh
and with the new york jets never like i
don't know took
personal shots at anybody so that that's
where i'm intrigued by it i mean andy
reid we know is like the ultimate
player's coach
and does so many things you know the
players love and everything like that
you know but we saw a similar scenario
the year before with lesean mccoy
you know again that's the role he was
brought in you weren't there to be like
the meat and potatoes guy you were there
to be
like the veteran like we got a little
you know
we got a guy here who's got experience
and knows how to play
but you're not the main guy but
obviously le'veon bell feels like he
should have had more of like a niche
within the offense and that's just not
the case and yeah it's not a good look
for him we're not gonna get him a new
job talking like that
we had the explanation up on the screen
for his comments he says i said what i
said and i don't regret at
all what i said for those who have a
personal problem with me because of what
i said that's fine you have your right
just understand i also have my right for
how i feel about my personal problem
with dude andy reid because of what he
said to me
i'd love to know what reid said yeah
that pissed off le'veon bell
and it could just be that reid was the
first coach in a long time who told him
what he needed to hear
hey le'veon you're not leaving on bell
anymore i don't know who you are
but you're not that guy that we used to
have to game plan against to try to
figure out how to stop the steelers
that's not you anymore
i i i don't know without knowing what
was said
i i it's impossible to assess whether or
not le'veon bell's reaction is justified
chris
no i i mean agreed his his
reaction is not justified
no matter what really because of what
you're saying of what we see on the
field
you know there's nothing there to
justify it on the field like there's not
no one sitting there going
man andy reed i don't know what the deal
was le'veon bell last year was amazing
why didn't he play him more at the end
of the year
that that that's like so that's where
le'veon bell has to be careful because
you know there's nothing no evaluator or
real football fans going to watch and go
you got screwed over you were right you
were really awesome when you were out
there
you know and i like le'veon bell you
know that but yeah
i mean it's coming to an end or he's got
to change something
you know he's lost his explosiveness you
can see him in his body he's not as
thick and as powerful as he used to be
so i i don't know what went wrong there
but yeah i mean i think
it it could be a little bit of a trouble
for him to find a team here and he could
be one of those guys that kind of is
just waiting around
most of training camp said tyron matthew
in response to the kerfuffle these
fellas will blame
everybody for their lack of success
that's how i know
i'm built different and you know tyron's
got the right attitude
if you have failures if you have
shortcomings don't blame someone else
search your heart search your mind
search your soul for the things that you
can do
better and i don't know whether le'veon
bell just
lost his commitment to football i i
don't i don't know what it was
i don't know what it was something
prompted him to sit out all of the 2018
season and
and kudos to him for getting the money
he got from the jets the jets screwed
that up they didn't have the
infrastructure in place
to support a le'veon bell you don't
build a team from the outside in you
build it from the inside out
it was a huge mistake one of the worst
free agent signings of the past 20 years
but uh he did get his money and uh i
hope he saved it
and i'm not saying that sarcastically
there's only
a finite number of years as a for an nfl
player to have a high
level of earning potential and that's
got to last
because i don't think he's getting
anything more than the minimum if he
even gets an
offer to go play for someone for that
chris yeah i
i i agree i mean it's a part in his
career right now
where yes he's gonna get on a team
look at it as really a third string type
running back
if injuries happen then you start to get
in the rotation
yes you've been around you know blitz
pickups you can catch the football
do those type of things but yeah we're
getting to the end here
we really are and i really would think
this is his last chance
unless he does something kind of
significant or really shows real
progress this year
i would think this is about it if he
even gets this chance i think it could
be interesting that
to that degree it may be done yeah it
might have
pressed the self-destruct button because
whoever coaches him next
is going to be the next guy who gets
called out when it doesn't work
on social media that's what i
the the kids who are growing up in
social media don't
seem to understand that when you use
that to
air out your boss or complain about this
at work or that at work future employers
are going to look at that and say
that may be me someday so i'm not going
to hire this person
and a lot of i just it's astounding to
me how many people
don't understand that if you start
complaining about who's signing your
paycheck
the people who may be signing it in the
future maybe a little leery about
being in the crosshairs of your
criticism
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports